is this a sign Jordan do you think I I
felt that there is a movement going on
now of a real backlash my man Jordan
Peterson was on Piers Morgan show last
night and they talked about the Golden
Globes from a few days ago and how
there's been a shift away from all that
political yammering that we just showed
you I watched the Golden Globes last
night for example uh an event that was
taken off air last year in a row about
uh racial bias and so on in the
institution that puts it on uh and it
came back on really fascinating to me I
watched the whole thing for three hours
no political speeches no virtue
signaling no Grand standing people
basically did what Ricky Jes told them
to do three years ago which is get up
you know thank your agent and and sit
down and just celebrate making movies or
TV shows um is this a sign Jordan do you
think I I felt that there is a movement
going on now of a real backlash from
perhaps a majority that's been silent
till now that's just said enough and
that even Hollywood has woken up to the
reality that people who watch the movies
and TV show they don't want to hear this
stuff all the
time well we put politics first and
foremost and partly the reason we did
that was because any higher AIMS in some
ways collapsed I suppose that's part and
parcel of the famous death of God if
what's highest spiritually and
transcendentally disappears then
something else steps up to take its
place and in our society that's either
been a nihilistic bent that's very
powerful or politicking in general the
mistake that entertainers make is that
they regard what they do as mere
entertainment Hollywood stars and all
the people who were involved in
producing the narratives that entice and
and and uh compel us they Serv serving a
master who's High far higher than
anything merely political and when they
bend their art to serve a political
Master they distort the higher to the
lower to their own detriment the art
should never be subordinated to serve
the political because then it gets not
only does it get propagandistic it gets
dull and
contemptible no one cares what a star
thinks about Trump especially when what
they what they have to say about Trump
can be said just as coherently by your
demented
neighbor yes that is true and as your
demented neighbor I'm going to continue
for a moment so Jordan's point is that
art should be made for Art's Sake a
beautiful painting should be beautiful
because of what it brings out in you
that that that that actually is divine
and important but once that becomes
subservient to a political agenda you
get these hysterical people that that
are so incredibly self-righteous that
they think because they can pretend to
be an astronaut in a movie they can also
also tell you how to live your
life